arriva
alger la cassette du muezzin qui appelle
à la prière et diffuser cinq fois par
jour
[Musique]
ici l'islam est religion d'état
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'intégrisme et la rigueur musulmane
gagne du terrain
les réalisateurs de télévision et de
cinéma ne trouve plus de jeunes femmes
algériennes pour interpréter des rôles
d'amoureuse le plaisir le sexe ne sont
pas très bien vu et pourtant depuis
quelque temps une nouvelle musique
circule sur les hauteurs d'alger
tout a commencé au premier festival de
la jeunesse
c'est l'été dernier que la musique raï a
éclaté
[Musique]
nora et ça va être une musique qui va
peut-être révolutionné le monde de la
musique comme le prône la paix c'est
bien le reggae
[Musique]
bienne
il y a
il
eh bien
comment serait ce la réalité que la
jeunesse à gérer mais en même temps je
sais pas pourquoi peut-être à cause des
paroles qui pense c'est vulgaire pour
moi ça c'est pas la guerre c'est la
liesse s'est passé mais je vois là
serait toujours
c'est le couple entre les deux femmes
les disputes soit l'amour soit c'est pas
moi il ya beaucoup de choses
[Musique]
on la sent dans nos tripes quand on
entend la musique de rails ça donne une
image de la femme vraiment elle gueule
on la ressent essentielle ment quoi
dès qu'il ya des gens qui disent ils
auraient
chanté l'oreille ça va s'approcher du
site c'est parce que leurs aliments dans
la débauche voilà combat mais rien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai tout le monde n'apprécie pas
le rail surtout dans la casbah
et celle des arts on est dans une
tradition on a des coutumes on peut par
l'employeur écouter de la musique comme
ça avec un fer ou là qu'une soeur ou
avec qui on écoute ce alors jouer seul
ou avec chez son copain de huy où l'eau
est là par exemple on empanne casbah ce
que je peux mettre une cassette de rails
qu'est ce qui va se passer si je sors
je ne sais pas g
[Musique]
qui est déjà
tu y as
idole des jeunes algériens ne s'appelle
plus rock this town michael jackson ni
raïna raï cheb khaled les nouvelles
stars du raï
ce sont eux qui ont ramené cette musique
d'oran et remplacer les instruments
traditionnels par des guitares
électriques et les synthétiseurs
[Musique]
à l'origine cette musique marginal d'air
elle est interdite à la télévision elle
est interdite à la radio s'est très bien
passé et c'est tout ça à cause des
paroles parce que les paroles sont assez
salée assez
rude à ces familles comme les familles
sont très conservatrices très tout ça
par rapport à l'ancien par rapport au
principe
de la famille par rapport à pas mal de
choses à prouver à son épouse de choses
et cassettes de raï se vendent par
centaines de milliers et la musique
qu'elle diffuse rendent brûlante les
muses algérienne
[Musique]
je pense que j'ai l'interdît justement
qui a fait que cette musique après année
sort considérable en algérie et on est
toujours attiré par l'interdît c'est une
mini révolution c'est ils sont au rejet
de tabou de principe donc les jeunes en
ont ras-le-bol et là il exprime
tout ce qui leur est enlevée quoi tout
ce qui leur est interdit parlant par
cette mesure
notre jeunesse aspire à plus de
bien-être que la spirra beaucoup plus
d'instruction qu'elle aspire à beaucoup
plus de 2 d'expression et tout ça et on
n'a pas tous ses moyens faut dire ça
c'est une réalité 1
[Musique]
est ce que vous ne craignez pas nous on
a vu par exemple dans des boîtes des
jeunes
cinquante d'années qui ressemblait tout
à fait à des européennes ne crois pas
qu'on en pense quoi que la jeunesse de
nos yeux de nos jours partout dans le
monde ont été particulièrement en
algérie s'exprime corporellement cette
façon là est absolument aucun mal il
faut pas y voir du mal il faut habituer
la société à ne pas y voir du mal moi je
préfère quelqu'un qui pense plutôt
quelqu'un qui voit dans une cave pour
respirer de l'essence
deux voitures ou quelque chose qu'on
verrait les choses m pokora
part des choses notre sens toujours 5 tu
râles j'ai toujours la cassette du
millésime
mais aujourd'hui les moins de 25 ans
représentent 70% de la population
algérienne pour eux le rail n'est pas
seulement un son nouveau comme le
rock'n'roll pour nous il ya trente ans
le rail c'est pour tous ces jeunes une
façon de dire on est là et on compte
bien vous montrer
[Musique]